نبدا بالعناوين
لنصب مئات الصواريخ في الاراضي السوريه
الرئيس الايرانيه يصف المتظاهرين بالاعداء
والامن يلاحقوا عائلات المعارضين
الامم المتحده تحذر من عواقب منع
الافغانيات من العمل في المنظمات
القيود على المراه
وفي ملفات الخامسه من الطاقه والاغذيه الى
صواريخ كوريا الشماليه ارقام نقيه ل 20 22
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من تصريحات
رئيس هيئه الاركان الاسرائيليه افيكو خافي
والذي اكد ان السلاح النووي الايراني يظل
اكبر تهديد محتمل
اشار الى ان عمليه صنع القرار تتغير
عالميا اذا امتلكت ايران هذا السلاح كشف
ان اسرائيل احبطت مخطط ايران لنشر مئات
الصواريخ في سوريا مشيرا الى ان لدى تل
ابيب المزيد بما يجب ان تفعله بشان الوجود
الايراني في سوريا
ستتغير عمليه صنع القرار بالكامل لجميع
اللاعبين في العالم تماما بمجرد ان تمتلك
ايران سلاح نوويا للاغراض العسكريا لقد
تحسن مستوى استعداد ايران لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي جاهز لاي اوامر ضد نووي ايران
وسيلتزم بالمهام الموكله اليه وقمنا
بالفعل باحباط مخطط ايران لنشر مئات
الصواريخ في سوريا ولدينا المزيد مما
سنفعله
كخافي شدد على ضروره ان يشمل التصدي
لايران كل وكلائها وانشطتهم في الشرق
الاوسط ضمن الرؤيه شامله الى جانب الملف
النووي مشيرا الى ان ايران كشفت من
انشطتها المزعزع للاستقرار في السنوات
الاخيره ايضا متابعه
تتجاوز الحدود الجغرافيه للبلد المسمى
ايران اولا وقبل كل شيء هو التهديد
المحتمل للقدره النوويه العسكريه وبجانبها
هناك قضيه ثاني رئيسيه اخرى
جميع انشطه الوكلاء الايرانيين في جميع
انحاء الشرق الاوسط وما وراءه في افريقيا
واماكن اخرى الى جانب القوات العسكريه
والبنيه التحتيه الايرانيه في لبنان
وسوريا التحركات الايرانيه حمله متعدده
الابعاد جويه وبحريه وبريه وسبرانيه في
المنطقه كلها من يظن ان هذه الحمله تجري
فقط على الاراضي السوريه فهو مخطا انها
تحتضن الشرق الاوسط باكمله على مستويات
مختلفه وهي حمله تم تكثيفها في السنوات
الاخيره
من تصريحاتكم خافي وتفسير لما ذكروا قال
انه عمليه صنع القرار ستتغير عالميا لجميع
اللاعبين عن من يتحدث هنا عن لائحه
الاصدقاء ام الاعداء
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع شلونه
سنحاول العوده اليه في سياق هذه النشره
ونكمل الى ملف الاحتجاجات المتساعده في
ايران وصف الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
المتظاهرين الايراني بالاعداء وهددهم
بمعامله قاسيه وتوعد رئيس في كلمه له في
حفل حكومي بجامعه طهران امام اعضاء البسيج
المعارضين بعدم الرحمه كما تهم الرئيس
الايراني وسائل اعلام بالتورد في
الاحتجاجات والترويج للجهل كما هدد مؤسسات
اعلاميه ناطقه بالفارسيه في الخارج تاتي
تهديدات رئيس بعد اعدام اثنين من
المتظاهرين في ما يواجه العشرات من
المحتجين المعتقلين خطر الاعدام ومنذ
اندلاع الاحتجاجات قد قتل النظام الايراني
ما لا يقل عن 500 متظاهر بالرصاص الحي
ونفذ اعتقلات واسعه طالت صحفيين ايضا
وكانت مجموعه نشطاء حقوق الانسان في ايران
هارانا قد اعلنت ان القضاء الايراني اعدم
565 شخصا بما فيهم 11 امراه وخمسه اطفال
بحسب تقرير المجموعه فان تنفيذ احكام
الاعدام ارتفع بالنسبه 88 بالمئه مقارنه
بعام 2021 وقد شهد صدور هذه الاحكام نموا
بنسبه 8% في الشهر الماضي فقد تم اعدام
مشابين يبلغان من العمر الثلاثه وعشرين
عاما بعد تاكيد الحكم من قبل المحكمه
العليا احدهما كان مجيد رضا
والذي تم اعدامه على من في مشهد ودون علمه
اسرته
مع تاكيدات التقارير المنظمات الدوليه
والحقوقيه بمقتل اطفال عياد الامن
الايرانيه خلال قمع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
انتشر مقطع مصور لميثم مير فلك وهو يبكي
ولده البالغ من العمر 10 سنوات والذي قتل
برصاص الامن الايراني قبل 40 يوما نتابع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مناعه عائلته اسطوره كره القدم
الايرانيه من السفر بعد ان كانوا متجهين
من طهران الى دبي طبعا حدث غير مسبوق
عاشته هذه العائله الثاني او الدادائي
والذي لفت انتباه السلطات الايرانيه مؤخرا
لدعمه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في البلاد التي
اندلعت منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر معلومات
نقلتها مصادر اعلاميه ايرانيه افادت بان
رحله شركه ماهان كانت متجهه الى دبي وتقل
زوجته وابنه عليدائي اجبرت على الهبوط في
مطار كيس جنوبيه ايران قال شهود عيان ان
قوات الامن اقتحمت الطائره بعضها
اجبرت اسره اللاعب الشهير على النزول بحجه
انها ممنوعه من مغادره البلاد حتى الان
ليس هناك اي اثبات على صدور امر قضاء
الفعل لمنع السفر ورده على اجراء النظام
الايراني قال علي داي انه اذا كانت عائلته
ممنوعه من المغادره بالفعل لكان جهاز
الجوازات طبعا التابع للشرطه في ايران قد
اكتشف ذلك قبل صعود زوجته وابنته الى
الطائره
على كل انواع بعد ثلاثه اشهر من اعلان رجل
الاعمال الامريكي الى الماس انه سيوفر
خدمه الانترنت للمحتاجين في الداخل
الايراني عبر خدمه ستار لينك للاقمار
الصناعيه في سبتمبر الماضي اكد ماسك ان
شركته تقترب من حيازه مئه جهاز ستار لينك
يعمل في ايران حاليا متابعه
الانترنت صوت الاحتجاجات في ايران الذي
يصل اصداه الى العالم رغم محاوله النظام
اسكاته هذه المره من الفضاء
مئه محطه استقبال ارضيه لخدمه الانترنت
المؤمنه عبر شركه ستارلينج للاقمار
الصناعيه تعمل في ايران حاليا
هذا ما اعلن عنه رئيس شركه سبيس اكس
الملياردير الامريكي
نشر فيها مقطع فيديو قال انه التقط في
شوارع ايران معتبرا انه الان توجد حريه
اكبر للنساء في اختيار ما اذا كنا يريدنا
تغطيه شعرهن املاح اعلان ماسك عن المئه
جهاز التي تعمل بالفعل في ايران تاتي كفاء
بالوعد كان قطعه في سبتمبر الماضي اذا
اعلن حينها انه سيعمل على اتاحه الانترنت
عبر شبكته للاقمار الصناعيه في ايران في
وقت تفرض فيه السلطات المزيد من القيود
على الانترنت لمنع ايصال صوت المتظاهرين
الى الخارج
وستعمل خدمه النطاق العريض المعتمده على
الاقمار الصناعيه في مساعده الايرانيين في
الالتفات على قيود امه المفروضه للوصول
الى الانترنت وبعض منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي وسط الاحتجاجات وهو ما سيكل
مصدر ضغط جديد على النظام الايراني
في نشره الخامسه وتصريحات رئيس هيئه
الاركان الاسرائيليه التي تحدث فيها عن ان
السلاح النووي الايراني هو التهديد الاول
بالنسبه لاسرائيل ايضا تحدث عن احباط
اسرائيل لمخطط ايراني للنشر اكثر من 100
او 100 الصواريخ في سوريا اضافه لنقطه كنت
بداتها مع الحديث مع ضيف من القدس شلون
وجنور المحلل السياسي قبل ايام قطع
الاتصال وسالته بهذا الاطار عن فحوى ما
ذكره رئيس هيئه الاركان الاسرائيليه عندما
قال بانه عمليه صنع القرار ستغير عالميا
بحال حصلت ايران على هذا السلاح النووي
وذلك لجميع اللاعبين والسؤال هنا اعود
واكرره عن من نتحدث هنا عن لائحه الاصدقاء
ام الاعداء شلونه
طيب
الخامسه مستمره فيها لكن بعد الفاصل
في حديث نادر الكويت تشهد تقاص تساقط
البرد في عدد من المناطق
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامس انتقد سفيره
الحكومه الافغانيه السابقه لدى النمسا
مانيزا بختري انتقدت مسؤوليه بعثه الامم
المتحده هناك في افغانستان قالت بختري لنا
مسؤوليه بعثه الامم المتحده هناك يحاولون
تبييض صفحه طالبان وتطبيع العلاقات معها
من خلال تظليل الراي العام العالمي كما
اتهمت البعثه الاميه بالوقوف ضد الشعب
الافغاني بتقديم تقارير غير عادله تتجاهل
الانتهاكات الجسيمه لحقوق الانسان
الى ذلك ادانت مفوضيه حقوق الانسان في
الامم المتحده زياده القيود على حقوق
المراه في افغانستان قال مفوض حقوق
الانسان ترك لانه لا يمكن لدوله ان تتطور
او تبقى على الصعيد الاجتماعي والاقتصادي
مع استبعاد النصفي سكانها واشار الى ان
القيود التي فرضتها طالبان ضد النساء لا
يمكن استيعابها ولا يؤدي ذلك الا الى
زياده معاناه جميع الافغان وستشكل خطرا
خارج حدود افغانستان اضاف ايضا ان حضر عمل
النساء في المنظمات غير الحكوميه سيحرمهن
ويحرم اسرهن من الدخل ومن حق الاسهام
بايجابيه في تنميه البلاد
وفي افغانستان ايضا منظمات الاغاثه تعلق
عملها في افغانستان اعتراضا على هذا
القرار قرار طالبان من عالاف السيدات من
العمل في قطاع الاغاثه
وثمانيه وثلاثون مليون يواجهون مخاوف
الجوع في التفاصيل حذرت القائمه بالاعمال
الامريكيه في افغانستان من ان قرار طالبان
سيؤدي الى المجاعه وجاء في بيان المشترك
صادر عن منظمات انقذوا الاطفال والمجلس
النرويجي للاجئين وكير انه سيتم تعليق
برامج الاغاثه بانتظار اتضاح الصوره بشان
هذا الاعلان وطلبت هذه المنظمات بمواصله
الرجال والنساء وبشكل متساون العمل على
تقديم المساعدات التي تنقذ الارواح في
افغانستان فيما وصل عدد المؤسسات الاغاثيه
التي جمدت عملياتها احتجاجا على قرار
طالبان الى سته حتى هذه اللحظه
المزيد ينضم الينا من كابو المراسل
العربيه عبد الله نادر اهلا بك عبدالله
اسمح لي انا ابدا بقراءه بتصريحات سفيره
افغانستان في النمسا السابقه انتقدت فيها
الامم المتحده البعثه الامم يعتبرتها تقوم
بالتطبيع بالتضليل الى اخره هل تتلمسون
هذا على الارض عن ماذا تتحدث
نعم من الممكن ان تكون هناك همم يعني
انتهاك لحقوق البشر وكذلك
انتهاكات اخرى في الاراضي الافغانيه لان
الاراضي الافغانيه شاسعه ولا ليست هناك
مؤسسات مستقله او دوليه وامنيه تستطيع ان
تحتوي هذه المناطق همم باكملها همم
منظمات الدوليه والمنظمات الاميه همم
تتواجد فقط في المدن الكبرى كالعاصمه كابل
مدينه هيرات في المقاطعات الغربيه
اسمح لي هي تتحدث عن نوع من التضليل حتى
في التقارير بمعنى اخر وكانها تقول بان
ذلك بشكل مقصود
انت تقول عكس ذلك انه هي غير قادر على
الوصول لتغطيه كل ما يحدث على الارض
هي ان المنظمات الدوليه والمنظمات
الحكوميه لحد الان ومنذ 40 عاما لم تستطع
استيعاب واحتواء القضايا البشريه
والانتهاكات الجسديه التي وقعت تقع في في
الاراضي الافغانيه اما ما تقصده هذه
السفيره فمن الممكن انها قرات وتابعت هذا
الملف ليس لدي معلومات اضيفه حول هذه
التصريحات معلومات
عن ما يحدث وتاثير قرار طالبان وايضا
بالمقابل كانت فعل تعليق العمل من قبل بعض
المنظمات على الوضع همم وضع الناس على
الارض
نعم اذا استمر هذا القرار في تعميله فان
ملايين من الافغاني سوف يتضررون من مغبه
هذا القرار فيما تقول الامم المتحده بان
لديه برامج خدمه اييه ل 19 شخصا افغانيا
بينهم اكثر من 10 ملايين طفل وهؤلاء وهذا
العدد الهائل سوف يتضرر من هذا القرار
الذي اتخذته طالبا مؤخرا ااه بعدم العم
عمل السيدات في المنظمات دول وفي منظمات
الامم المتحده فيما تقول منظمه يونسكو
منظمه الامم المتحده للطفوله بان هذا
القرار يخلق مشاكل كثيره في تقديم وايصال
الخدمات للاسر والاطفال الافغانيه وكتبت
ليله الماضيه منظمه الاطباء الاطباء بلا
حدود همم على صفحتها في تويتر بان هذه
المنظمه همم بدات تنشيطتها في الاراضي
الافغانيه منذ اكثر من 40
ولكنها اكدت كذلك بان هذه المنظمه ليست
قادره في ايصال وتقديم الخدمات الصحيه في
افغانستان دون مشاركه المراه
وتعتبر او تعتقد منظمه الامم بعثه بعثه
الامم المتحده هنا ما في افغانستان بان
ملايين من الافغان المستضعفين سوف يتاثرون
من هذا القرار سلبا فيما همم نظم عدد من
من الممثله المنظمات الامميه والدوليه
اجتماعا وجلسه مع همم القائم باعمال همم
الصحه الافغانيه قلنا ده العباد
وطالبت وطالبه هؤلاء الممثلون
طالبان بالتراجع من هذا القرار لان
الخدمات وخاصه الخدمات الصحيه لا تن لا
يمكن تقديمها دون مشاركه النساء بحسبها
اول ايام الممثلين
كاس العربيه عبد الله نادر شكرا جزيلا لك
الى الملف الاوكراني الان قال وزير
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه دي متروكوليبا ان
بطاريات باتريه الامريكيه ستكون جاهزه
للعمل في اقل من سته اشهر وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه جدد رغبه بلاده في عقد قمه
دوليه في غضول شهرين لانهاء الحرب مؤكدا
للدعوه لمحاكمتي روسيا عن جرائم الحرب قبل
اي مفاوضات كما قالها
الثاني فكره صيغه السلام ستكون ذات شقين
اولها عدم السماح لروسيا بالتلاعب بقضيه
السلام لانهم يقولون باستمرار انهم
مستعدون للمفاوضات وهذا غير صحيح لان كل
ما يفعلونه في ساحه المعركه يثبت العكس
تماما اما الشوط الثاني هو محاكمه روسيه
عن جرائم الحرب
وتفاعل مع الدعوه الاوكرانيه لعقد قمه
السلام مع روسيا قالت المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريت قالت
انه لن يتوسط في حل الازمه الاوكرانيه الا
بموافقه جميع الاطراف بما فيها روسيا
مزيد مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بك
حذيفه بدايه اخر التطورات الميدانيه
هي محور باخ موت ومحور همم
في منطقه لغاز كان محور المشتعل هو المحور
كوبيسك وهي المدينه التي يحاول الان الجيش
الاوكراني الوصول والسيطر عليها وقال
جيدايس جاي جاي جاي يحاكم المقاطعه قال
انهم اقتربوا من السيطر على هذه المدينه
ولكن وقال ايضا ان مخاوف الجيش الروسي من
السيطره الاوكرانيين على هذه المدينه انه
سيكون اختراق كبير للجيش الاوكراني في خط
الدفاع الجيش الاوكراني في منطقه وذلك
سيسبب خسائر كبيره للجيش الروسي بعد ذلك
نسبه لانه سيكون هناك امكانيه للتقدم همم
السيطره عليها سابقا من قبل الاتحاد
الروسي طبعا في منطقه تشهد عمليات قصر من
قبل الاتحاد الروسيه تمتص همم تم تنفيذ 40
الضربه صاروخيه بانظمه اطلاق صواريخ
متعدده في ال 24 ساعه الماضيه وتم عمليه
اشتباك واطلاق نار على كامل الخطه الجبهه
في باخمج ومتى فيما يتعلق بالكهرباء
والمياه ايضا حذيفه
الكهرباء الامداد الكهربائي في جميع المدن
الاوكرانيه دون استثناء قد يكون الغرب
الاوكراني اقل تضررا درجه ولكنه يعاني
ايضا طبعا من قطاعات طويله جدا ليها
الكهرباء في الشبكه وطبعا همم انقطاع
الكهرباء يمتد الى انقطاع في التدفئه وفي
المياه واا سوء في الخدمات وكان الاتصالات
وغيرها همم لذلك الوضع ماساوي وكان همم
الغربه الاوكراني او في وسط طبعا العاصمه
ايضا تعاني معركه كبيره جدا شمالا البلاد
المنطقه الشقيقه وفولها الكره كامله همم
يعني لم يعد التيار اليها منذ الهجوم
الاخير هو جاري العمل على استعاده التيار
في تلك المناطق وطبعا المنطقه
الاكبر في الشرق الاكراني كل ما اقتربنا
من خط النار هنالك ايضا كره كامله تعيش
دون كهرباء دون مياه دون غاز دون تدفي ذلك
وصعوبه الوصول اليها سمعنا قبل قليل رد
الفعل اا الاممي تحديدا المتحدثه باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده حول الدعوه
الاوكرانيه
لعقد مؤتمر سلام همم قال الامين العام بما
معناه بانه لن يتوسط الا بوافقه جميع
الاطراف كيف تتفاعل كيب او اي ردود فعل
على هذه التصريحات
ويحتاج الى شرح كبير طبعا الجانب
الاوكراني يتحدث عن صيغه سلام اوكرانيه
هذا ما ينظر اليه المراقبون بانه اصبح
بشروط استسلام يعني المحللين اليوم هنالك
لا يوجد حديث سوى هذا الموضوع انه الصيغه
الاوكرانيه والصيغه الروسيه همم
وهي صيغه الاستسلام كامل وهو ما لا يمكن
ان يحدث الا بهزيمه احد الطرفين على ارض
المعركه طبعا انهم سيعقدون هذه عازمون على
عقد هذه القمه في نهايه فبراير بصيغه سلام
اوكرانيه علق على ذلك الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديميرسي في خطاب اليوم للشعب الاوكراني
وقال انه سعيد همم وجد انه ينظر لي صيغه
السلام الاوكرانيه بشكل ايجابي وقال كل ما
اسرعنا في تنفيذ صيغه الصلاه والسلام
ولغرب ولكن ايضا التعليق الاول من قبل
الاتحاد الروسي ديميتري بواسكي وهو العضو
المنتدى الدائم
روسيا في الامم وحيد قالها يعني ابتداء
اشار الى رغبه اوكرانيا في استبعاد روسيا
من مجلس الامن وقال اي صيغه سلام يمكن ان
تكون بدون روسيا واي قيمه يمكن انت تعقد
بدون روسيا العربيه حذيفه شكرا جزيلا لك
ومشاهدينا ننقل لكم هذه الصور التي تصلنا
الان مباشره من مدينه بافلو في ولايه
نيويورك الامريكيه كما نشاهد من خلال هذه
الصور العاصفه الثلجيه تتواصل ونلاحظ ايضا
ان المدينه تعاني من شلل تام طبعا
المعلومات التي وردتنا تتحدث عن الناس
علقوا بالثلج في سياراتهم طبعا هناك عدد
من القتلى ايضا عدد من الاصابات انقطاع في
التيار الكهربائي وايضا في الماء
اذا شلل كامل يصيب هذه المدينه مدينه
بافلو في نيويورك بسبب تراكم الثلوج وطبعا
وصفت هذه العاصفه بانها الاقصى التي تمر
على البلاد ادت الى اغلاق المطارات تاجيل
الرحلات والغائها وايضا الى قطع الطرقات
الرئيسيه من منطقه الى اخرى وكمان نشاهد
هذا الشلل التام في هذه المدينه الان لا
سيارات لا حركه للناس لا كهرباء لا تدفئه
نعود الى الملف الاوكراني حيث يرى خبراء
عسكريون ان القوات الروسيه ستبدا
استراتيجيه عسكريه جديده في الحرب التي
تخوضها على الاراضي الاوكرانيه تبدا مع
انتهاء فصل الشتاء الاستراتيجيه المتوقعه
تتمثل في محاوله اسقاط العاصمه كليف مع
تقييد الهجمات الاوكرانيه في ان كان
خارقين وخرسون الى جانب التركيز على احكام
السيطره على كامل اقليم الدمباز التفاصيل
في هذا التقرير
ميدان المعركه الروسيه الاوكرانيه مشتعل
في تصعيد المستمر منذ الرابع والعشرين من
فبراير الماضي ثلاث مراحل تنوعت فيها
اشكال
واستراتيجيات القتال من قبل الجيش الروسي
ومرحله الرابعه على وشك البدء خبراء
المرحله الاولى هي التي تعثر فيها الجيش
الروسي في كيا وتر نيفاف والمرحله الثانيه
هي التي تحول فيها القتال من كتاب الى
اقليم دومباز اما المرحله الثالثه فهي
استعاده اوكرانيا
في جميع تلك المراحل قاتل الجيش الروسي
بالخطوط الخارجيه على جبهه ممتده من كييف
شمالا الى خرسون جنوبا مشاكل نقص الامداد
وغياب القياده الموحده لكل جبهات
القوات الروسيه ستبدا مرحله الرابعه بعد
ذوبان ثلوج الشتاء وهدوء عواطفه ابرز
ملامحها قد تكون العوده الى اسقاط العاصمه
كييف عبر بيلاروسيا مع تقييد الهجمات
الاوكرانيه في خاركه بوخارسون والتركيز
على احكام السيطره على كامل اقليم جمباز
مع محاوله استرداد الاراضي التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش الاوكراني في الاقاليم
الاربعه التي ضمها الرئيس بوتين وخصوصا
زابوريجيا
وجه جديد للمعارك قد يشهد كذلك دخوله بلا
روسيا الى المعادله خاصه ان بعض المؤشرات
تقول ان روسيا بدات ارسال القوات المسرعه
اليها مع نشر منظومه صواريخ اس 4
والصواريخ البالستيه من نوع اسكندر ملوك
الشيخ العربي
مشاهدينا نقل ايضا هذه الصور التي تاتينا
الان او وردتنا قبل قليل لحريق في مصفاه
لاناز النفطيه على طريق اربيل في منطقه
الكويره بالعراق اذن تصاعد للدخان حتى
الان لم تتم السيطره على هذا الحريق الذي
اندلع في هذه المصفاه في اربيل عاصمه
كردستان طبعا الحرائق هناك ليست جديده كان
في شهر خمسه ايضا اندلاع لحريق ولكن في
ذلك الوقت كان بسبب استهداف لعدد من
الصواريخ مصفاه نفط في اربيل بشمال العراق
وفي حينها الدال اندلاع حريق باحد خزاناته
وهذه صور لليوم ولهذا الاستهداف الجديد او
للحرائق الجديده لا نعلم الاسباب الحقيقيه
حتى الان اا وان كان هناك اي خسائر بشريه
او اي تفاص اوف حول سبب اندلاع هذا الحريق
طبول الحرب تقرا على الحدود بين صربيا
وكزب الرئيس الصربي وضع الجيش في حاله
تاهب تام وزاد عدد الجنود من 1500 الى
5000 جندي بذريعه ان كوسوفو تسلح الالبان
داون نتابع
مشهد يشبهوا الى حد كبير مشهد حشد القوات
الروسيه على الحدود الاوكرانيه لتشتعل
الحرب بعدها
تاهب قتالي كامل على الحدود بين صربيا
واقليم كوسوفو في تصعيد جديده
بوضع القوات الصربيه في حاله التاهب
ليرتفع عدد الجنود من 10500 جندي حاليا
الى خمسه الاف بالجراند تتذرع بما خاوي في
تسليح الباني كوسوفو متمسكه بحمايه
المواطنين في صربيا بعد نشر وسائل الاعلام
اخبار عن شنه هجوم على المناطق الصربيه
الشماليه
لكننا سنبذروا قصار جهدنا وسنحرص على حفظ
السلام والاستقرار ليس ذلك فحسب بل سنعمل
على حمايه شعبنا في شمال سوف هي بعد تسليح
البانيو كوسوفو ورفع استعدادهم القتاليه
ساتخذ جميع الاجراءات الضروريه لحمايه
شعبنا وحمايه صربيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي للتهدئه وعدم الاتجاه
نحو التصعيد تتجاهلها بالجراد لكن الكتله
الاوروبيه حذرت من اي عواقب لعمل عسكري
فلم ترد على مزاعم الهجوم على صرب كسوفو
الا انها كانت قد اتهمت الرئيس الصربي
بممارسه الالعاب بهدف اثاره المتاعب
التوترات هي والدته سنوات طويله من النزاع
بين الطرفين الا ان الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا زادت من مخاوف اثاره البركان شبه
الخامد بين صربيا وكوسوفو لتكون ابسط
الشرارات التي ظهرت مؤخرا كالقاء القبض
على شرطي سابق من قبل سلطات كوسوفو وتحديد
بريشتينا موعده للانتخابات المحليه
كفيله باشعال نار الحرب الى عمر العربيه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
عاصفه القرن الثلجيه تواصل ضرب الولايات
المتحده وولايه نيويورك الاكثر تضررا
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه طلبه قوات حفظ
السلام الامميه في لبنان بمحاسبه الجنات
في مقتل الجنديه الايرلندي ذلك بعد ان
اعلن الجيش اللبنانيه اعتقال المجتبه
بمقتل الجندي الايرلندي ضمن قوات حفظ
السلام الامميه في لبنان اليونيفيل وكانت
مصادر امنيه لبنانيه تحدثت منذ ايام عن
تسليم ميليشيا حزب الله لمشتبه بيبي حادثه
الاعتداء على قوات اليونيفيل
في العراق اكد المتحدث باسم القوات
المسلحه العراقيه اللواء يحيى رسول
لاستمرار في نشر القوات المسك الخط الصفري
على الحدود بين العراق وكل من سوريا
وايران وايضا تركيا مشددا في تصريحات
للعربيه على الدفاع عن سياده العراق ورفض
استخدام اراضيه لتهديد اي دوله جاره
على الحدود العراقيه التركيه
وايضا وجه بتعزيز هذه القياده بكل ما
تحتاجه من اشخاص ومعدات وكل الدعم
اللوجستي كذلك مسك المخاطر الحدوديه وزاره
الداخليه اخذت على اعتقد متابعه من قبل
السيد علي وزير الداخليه هذا الموضوع
اعتقد خطوات كبيره كانت بعمليه مسك الخط
الصفري
واعتقد هذه النقطه مهمه جدا هو النمسك هذه
الحدود والخط الصدري في نفس الوقت
يدافع عن سياده العراق وفي نفس الوقت لا
نقبل او نؤيد ان تكون الاراضي العراق
المنطلق للقيام باي عمل الارهابي باتجاه
اي دوله
تشهد وكاله السياحه والاسفار في الصين
اقبالا واسعا من طرف المواطنين قبيل اعاده
فتح حدود البلاد بعد ان قررت الحكومه
الغاء القيود المرتبطه بفايروس كورونا في
وقت تواصلوا فيه البلاد تسجيل مستويات
قياسيه في عدد الاصابات التي تخطط تعتبت
المليون اصابه في اليوم في بعض المناطق
السفر
تحديدا ثلاث سنوات صعبه وطويله مرت بها
البلاد التي كانت بؤره للوباء الذي غير
مجرى حياتهم وحياته العالم باسره بعد
اسابيع فقط من تخلي بكين عن سياستها
الصارمه لاحتواء الوباء والتي صاحبها
تسجيل معدلات قياسيه في الاصابات اجراء
جديد
تمثل برفع قيود السفر والتنازل عن
الاختبار والحجر الصحي للمسافرين خصوصا
الوافدين
بطريقه علميه
لا مزيد من الاجراءات المرهقه لكل
المسافرين والوافدين للصين فشركات السياحه
والسفر وبمجرد اعلان الحكومه عن هذا
القرار عرفت اقبالا كبيلا قبيل اعاده فتح
حدود البلاد في الثامن من يناير للعام
المقبل
لقد كنت متحمسا للغايه عندما سمعت الخبر
كان غير متوقع كنت اتطلع اليها كنت اسافر
كثيرا وانا متعطش للسفر
من سنوات لذلك ستكون هناك زياده هائله في
عدد الاشخاص المسافرين اجراء سرعان منعكس
اقبالا على مواقع السفر واظهرت بيانات
منصه السفر تضعف عمليات البحث عن وجهات
السفر في غضون نصف ساعه فقط من تداول خبر
رفع قيود الحجر الصحي وتصدر تايلاند
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه الوجهات
الثمن من يناير من العام المقبل يمثل خطوه
حاسمه لاعاده فتح الصين امام العالم وهنا
سيتمكن القاده الاجانب مره اخرى من السفر
الى بكين دون ان ينحصر في فقاعه صحيه خطوه
كبيره اتخذتها الحكومه الصينيه لاحتواء
الاستياء الشعبي وبحث السياحه من جديد
وايضا لتدارك الاضرار الاقتصاديه المستمره
منذ العام 2020 والتي تسببت في ركود لم
يسبق مثيل في الاقتصاد الصيني
اعلن رئيس الوزراء اليابانيوميو كاشيتا
اليوم تجديد الضوابط الحدوديه للقادمين من
الصين ابتداءا من الثلاثين من ديسمبرغا
اجراء احترازي طبعا انتشار الفايروس
وتزايد الاصابات بالفيروس هناك
في ظل التقارير المتعلقه بالانتشار السريع
للعدوى في الصين تتباين المعلومات الوارده
من السلطات المركزيه والمحليه والمنظمات
الخاصه الى حد كبير هناك مخاوف متزايده في
اليابان بالنظر لهذا الموقف قررنا اتخاذ
اجراء طارق
القادمين من الصين و سيدخل حيز التنفيذ في
الساعه 12:00 صباحا من ال30 من ديسمبر
لعام 20 23 توقعات جاءت على لساندي متري
مدري نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي ورئيس
البلاد سابقا الذي اوضح ان الغرب سيواجه
مشكله كبيره خلال الفتره المقبله
[موسيقى]
في اخبار تويتر ذكرت شركه هاتسون روك
الاسرائيليه للمعلومات السبرانيه ان احد
قراصنه البيانات نجح في اختراق منصه
التواصل الاجتماعيه تويتر قالت بانه تمكن
من الاستيلاء على بيانات حوالي 400 مليون
مستخدم يعرضها للبيع على ما يعرف بدرك ويب
كما اشارت الى ان البيانات المسروقه تشمل
بيانات خاصه بمستخدمين مشهورين من ابرزهم
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه جوجل وزاره الاعلام
والاذاعه الهنديه والممثل الهندي الشهير
سلمان خان
من الارتفاع الحاد في الاسعار الى الحرائق
الواسعه مرورا بعهد الملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه التي وضعها حوالي 200 250 الف شخص
في كاتدرائيه وسمستر شهد عام 20 20 22
الكثير من الانجازات في كسر الارقام
القياسيه من ابرزها نتج عن الحرب
الاوكرانيه والتي دفعت اسعار الغاز في
اوروبا الى مستوى غير مسبوق فتسارع التضخم
الى مستوى قياسي جديد وارتفعت الاسعار
بمنطقه اليورو بمعدل سنوي قدره 10.7 طبعا
هو اكبر ارتفاع منذ اعتماد هذا المؤشر في
عام 1997 الصراع في اوكرانيا ادى ايضا الى
اكبر تدفق للاجئين في اوروبا منذ نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه مع مغادره اكثر من
سته ملايين شخص من اوكرانيا تجاه الدول
المجاوره وعلى صعيد المناخ شهد اوروبا
اكثر مواسم الصيف حرارا فيما اتت الحرائق
على اكثر من 600 الف هكتار وهو امر ايضا
غير مسبوق هذا العام ايضا استعرضت كوريا
الشماليه عضلاتها العسكريه حيث اطلقت عددا
قياسيا من الصواريخ باتجاه بحر اليابان
منها 23 صاروخا في غضون 24 ساعه الشهر
الماضي تزايدت الانجازات وتكاثر معها عدد
سكان العالم ليتجاوز ثمانيه مليارات نسمه
ما اعتبرته الامم المتحده نموا غير مسبوق
وبتلوه قدرت باكثر من مئه و99 مليار دولار
تصدر الى الماس قائمه اغنى اثرياء العالم
وهذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث اغسطس هذا العام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يبقى الموضوع التعاون
وفي اخبار موجه الطقس السيئه التي تضرب
المنطقه شهدت الكويت تساقط البلد في عدد
من المناطق على من ابرزها منطقه ميناء
الشعيبه في العاصمه
[موسيقى]
وما ادراك مات عيبه
الى سلطنه عمان التي شهدت مناطق عده فيها
ومنها العاصمه مسقط هطول امطار متفاوته
متفاوته الغزاره بدايه من صباح هذا اليوم
هذا لتعليق الدراسه في العاصمه تشير
التوقعات الى استمرار تاثر اجواء السلطنه
بحدود جوي حتى صباح الخميس المقبل
[تصفيق]
ومن عمان الى تبوك شمال غرب السعوديه التي
تضرب موعدا سنويا مع الثلوج دعونا نشاهد
ايضا هذه الصور من تساقط الثلوج على جبال
اللوز
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الخامس انتهت ولكن اترككم الان
مع هذه الصور العاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب
الولايات المتحده مشاهدينا
ابقى معنا
[موسيقى]